[Musique]
aujourd'hui quand vous prenez la somme
totale des crédits de trésorerie de
toutes les entreprises en france que sai
de l'auto entrepreneur à la très grande
entreprise
la somme de tous ces crédits trésorerie
en france et 240 milliards l état a mis
aux possibilités
un prêt qui permet de faire un bond sur
des besoins de trésorerie de 300
milliards payés 240 320
c'est quand même énorme le chêne
entreprise contacter sa banque pour dire
bah voila j'ai un besoin de trésorerie à
court moyen terme et nous on est là pour
les appuyer en disant bah voilà quel
peut être le scénario un petit peu
catastrophe prenons l'hypothèse la plus
pessimiste la ré ouverture tardive il
parlait de confinement qui se prononce
faut quand même l'avoir en tête
deuxièmement qu'est-ce que vous avez
encore en fournisseur a payé il va bien
falloir payer un jour ses charges
sociales ces charges fiscales et puis
aussi un autre sujet qu'on commence à
travailler c'est quand il va falloir
redémarrer l'activité de quoi allez vous
avoir besoin et les entreprises qui ont
besoin de recréer du stock appartements
ont aussi mis d'accord entre clients et
nous surnommons tant qu'on peut financer
le client va sur le site de l'abbaye
qu'un site extrêmement bien fait il y
voit là la bnp paribas est prête à me
prêter temps de milliers d'euros
là le crès école c'était générale le 6 7
ans le montant la bpi délivre un numéro
d'accord que le client nous communique à
partir de ce moment là on lui envoie une
offre de prêt en pdf
il ne l'a retourné en quelques jours
l'argent est crédité
[Musique]
la mesure prise par le gouvernement je
c'est du jamais vu
donc c'est un signal fort donné pour
aider le tissu économique local
le prêt garanti par l'état c'est un prêt
à 0 % pour les banques octroient un prêt
à 0 % le seul coût pour l'entreprise
c'est le coût de la garantie et c'est
0,25 la première année et au bout d'un
an l'entreprise à la plusieurs solutions
soit la capacité à rembourser par
anticipation secret très bien soit
l'entreprise souhaite amortir ce crédit
qui a été octroyée et apple l'amortir
sur une durée de un à cinq ans de coût
final c'est une capacité qui est donné à
l'entreprise d'avoir un prêt sur une
durée au total de 6 ans un taux très
faible